Whether it's on immigration
or tax returns
the president once again
reminded us this weekend
that he considers himself
above the law.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump toured the
border of Friday to once again
make the case that there is
a national emergency
happening there,
which there is not.
He touted a section
of the border wall
that had been planned during the
Obama administration
and in the process he invented a
new word.
-So behind us is the wall
That's the new wall.
we've done a lot of it.
And we're doing a lot more.
You see it over here.
Much of it's reinforced heavily.
And very, very hard to climb.
If you want to climb that,
pretty sharp up on top, too.
But it's a very, very hard
it's meant anti-climb.
It's called anti-climb.
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump went from being the
anti-crime candidate
to the anti-climb president.
He's an old man yelling at kids
to stay away from his oak tree.
"Don't climb that!
If you break your neck I ain't
gonna pay for it."
Trump also hosted a roundtable
event with border officials
and both at that event
and later at his tour of the
wall
he kept harping on
how good they looked.
-I want to thank
my men and women,
who do a tremendous job here
every day,
I'm very, very proud
of their commitment
even though they're facing
extreme challenges,
as you've heard.
-They're central casting.
I've never seen a group
of people like this.
Everyone is in perfect shape.
Central casting.
You don't have anybody
in Hollywood
that looks like these guys.
-I'm pretty sure --
I'm pretty sure they do.
At least in one of the suburbs.
I feel like maybe Pomona
or something.
Also, Trump is very obsessed
with central casting for a guy
who looks like the exact
opposite of a movie president.
If Trump went to
central casting,
they'd probably send him on
auditions for
"alcoholic Irish priest" or
"ghost who haunts a Queens OTB".
[ Laughter ]
The fifth horse in the sixth
race, bet it all.
Trump has been furious at Mexico
for supposedly
allowing migrants fleeing
poverty and violence
to come to the U.S.
seeking asylum.
Last week, for example,
he threatened to
close the border completely,
and when everyone,
including his own party,
warned that that would cause
an economic catastrophe,
Trump backed off and claimed
he was giving Mexico
a one-year warning
before he would impose tariffs
on Mexican imports.
-The only thing frankly better
but less drastic
than closing the border is
tariff the cars coming in,
and I will do it.
Just like him --
You know will do it.
I don't play games.
I'll do it. So we're doing it to
stop people.
We gonna give them
a one-year warning.
-Well, he's been promising to
build a wall for two years,
so if I were Mexico,
I wouldn't be that worried.
[ Laughter ]
A one-year warning
is such a lame threat.
He's like a high school bully
with no follow-through.
You better give me
your milk money, nerd,
or I'll beat you up as soon as
the McRib comes back.
[ Laughter ]
Trump has been
especially furious
about the asylum process.
Now it's both U.S.
and international right
to seek asylum.
But Trump doesn't care.
He has repeatedly painted
poor migrant families
seeking asylum as dangerous
threats and he did so again
in a rambling speech
over the weekend.
-The asylum program is a scam.
Some of the roughest people
you've ever seen,
people that look like they
should be fighting for the UFC.
-What?
Have you ever seen a UFC fight?
If Connor McGregor were trying
to sneak across the border,
people would notice.
Uh, chief,
we got a crazy Irish guy here,
trying to kick his way
through the wall.
-[ Irish accent ] Ah, can't
climb it, but I'll kick it!
This is anti-kick?
[ Laughter ]
Ah.
Trump doesn't care that we have
and established legal process
in this country
for applying for asylum.
That system involves making your
case in front of a judge.
It's a basic right enshrined in
U.S. and international law.
But Trump has been saying he
wants to get rid of that.
-We have to do something about
asylum.
And to be honest with you, have
to get rid of judges.
We have
a stupid system of ports,
it's the craziest thing
in the world.
They have to get rid of the
whole asylum system
because it doesn't work.
And frankly,
we should get rid of judges.
-Why do you want to get
rid of judges?
Is it because
they keep putting
everyone who works for you
in jail?
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
If we are going to keep judges,
they should have to pay for
our monster.com account
because we're getting killed
on staffing costs.
Maybe Trump wants to
get rid of judges
because he doesn't understand
what judges are
or how court cases work.
At the roundtable on Friday,
for example,
he blasted a court case
called "Reno V. Flores,
which protects migrant children
from being held indefinitely
in custody and grants them
certain basic rights
it's often referred to as
the Flores Decision.
Court cases are named after
parties involved
but Trump seems to think
that the case was named
after the judge who made
the decision.
-The Flores Decision is a
disaster.
I have to tell you Judge Flores,
whoever you may be,
that decision a disaster
for our country.
-There is no Judge Flores.
No one calls the O.J. Simpson
trial the "Lance Ito Case."
[ Laughter, applause ]
In fact,
Trump has been so furious
at his own administration's
inability to stop
legal asylum seekers
that on Sunday
he took the step of ousting
his own hardline
Secretary of Homeland security,
Kirstjen Nielsen
for not being tough enough
on immigration.
And her firing
leaves yet another
senior government position
filled by
a temporary official.
-After months of rumors and
speculation, Kirstjen Nielsen
is officially out as
Secretary of Homeland Security.
-She apparently bore the brunt
of the president's anger
over the issue of immigration.
-Now we will have an acting
Homeland Security Secretary
on top of an acting
Secretary of Defense,
Secretary of Interior,
on top of an acting
Ambassador to the United Nations
and then an acting
Chief of Staff.
-I mean this administration has
more staff turnover
than a Walmart on Black Friday.
I don't know what to tell you.
we're out of Hatchimals. You
know what? I quit. Good-bye.
Nielsen, of course,
oversaw and defended
the administration's horrific
policy of
separating migrant families
and she was
an enthusiastic advocate
for the Trump administration's
immigration policies.
At one point,
she even started mimicking
Trump's language
when she went to Congress
and asked for more
border wall funding.
-I will continue to work with
The Northern triangle countries,
with Mexico,
to help vulnerable populations
as soon as possible.
from Congress I would ask
for wall.
We need wall.
-We need wall.
I guess it's not surprising
they're ignoring articles
of the constitution, they're
ignoring articles altogether.
[ Laughter ]
Trump turns everyone --
Trump turns everyone
he works with into Tarzan.
It doesn't matter how smart
you are.
If Shakespeare had worked for
Trump, the line would have been
"Be or not be.
That is question."
The problem here
is pretty straightforward --
Trump thinks he should be able
to just ignore the law.
We've seen the same thing
play out this week
over his tax returns.
For months,
Trump has been building toward
a confrontation
with Democrats in Congress
over those tax returns.
Trump has promised
for years
that he would
eventually release them,
but he has repeatedly used
an obviously false excuse,
that he's always under audit.
It's an excuse
he started using in 2016
that has continued to repeat as
recently as last week.
-Are you going to release your
tax returns?
-At the appropriate time
I will release them,
but right now I'm under a
routine audit.
I don't mind releasing,
I'm under a routine audit,
an it'll be released and as soon
as the audit's finished,
it'll be released.
Look, as I told you,
they're under audit.
They're extremely complex.
People wouldn't understand them.
Every year they audit me,
audit me, audit me.
Nobody gets audi--
I have friends
that are very wealthy people,
they never get audited.
I've been audited every year.
I'm always under audit,
it seems.
I've been under audit
for many years
because the numbers are big and
I guess when you have a name,
you're audited.
-First of all
it's not when you have a name.
It's when you have your name.
If you had four bankruptcies
ties to mobsters
and lied about your net worth
your whole life,
you're going to get audited.
That's the easiest call
an IRS agent will ever make.
Who should we audit?
I don't know,
how about the guy
whose penthouse looks like
Goldmember's bathroom?
Second, this audit
is obviously not real.
It wasn't real
when he first said it in 2016
and there's no way it's taken
almost four years.
It can't be that hard
to find something fishy
in Trump's tax returns.
Just skim down to
the charity line
where he listed his adult sons.
Trump is the first President
in 40 years
not to release his tax returns.
And without them,
we have no idea
where he's getting money from
or who he owes money to.
Which is crazy.
He's the president.
You'd want to know
if your doctor
had a side business
running a mortuary.
Your test results were negative
but just in case,
have you thought about
a wood casket? Pine?
After Democrats won back
the house in November,
giving them subpoena power,
Trump warned
that he would resist attempts
to subpoena his tax returns.
And one point even said
he was bored by the question.
-Just a point of clarification
the tax returns issue,
you bought up the audit,
that doesn't prevent you
from releasing them.
-I know.
Sure but I didn't say it
prevented me
but I said lawyers will tell you
not to do it.
Go ahead.
What's your next question?
-Well, it,s just --
-Come on. Let's go.
More exciting question than
that, please.
-Oh, I'm sorry, are we
boring you, Caligula?
It's not their job
to entertain you.
Who'd win a fight,
a tiger or an alligator?
Now there we go,
that's a fun question.
[ Laughter ]
This is the White House,
not the Roman Coliseum.
They're not gonna
feed you grapes
while you watch them joust.
Kellyanne,
make the reporters fight.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
At that same press conference,
Trump also threatened
that there would be consequences
if Democrats subpoena
his tax returns.
-Do you expect that when the
Democrats take over
the chairmanship of all these
important committees
you're going to get hit
with a blizzard of subpoenas
on everything from
the Russia investigation --
-Well then it's going to come --
okay.
-To your cellphone use,
to your tax returns.
-Ready?
Then, you're going to,
if that happens,
then we're going to do
the same thing
and the government
comes to a halt.
-Comes to a halt?
The government
is already at a halt.
Forget the tax returns,
you shut the government down
for a month because you
didn't get your dumb wall.
Plus there's like
four people working there
and half the time
you're in Florida.
There are empty Blockbuster
video stores with more activity.
Honey, I --
Great news honey, I just rented
a VHS copy of "Forrest Gump"
from a very friendly squirrel.
That threat is telling
because Trump isn't
actually making
a legal argument,
he's simply saying
he doesn't care.
If you try to
hold him accountable,
he'll shut down the government.
That's it.
And this weekend, after
Democrats officially requested
six years of Trump's tax
returns from the IRS,
his Chief of Staff --
oh, excuse me,
his acting Chief of Staff,
Mick Mulvaney,
made a similar argument.
Mulvaney, said flat out
the Democrats would never get
Trump's tax returns no matter
what the law says.
-You believe Democrats
will never see
the president's tax returns?
-Oh, no. Never.
N-Nor should they.
-What do you mean never?
It's a congressional request.
You can't just turn it down like
hors d'oeuvres at a party.
you've been served.
Oh, no thank you I've already
had 100 Big Macs.
Whenever Trump
is threatened politically,
he becomes more lawless,
whether it's on immigration
or tax returns, he sees himself
as above that law.
He's painting immigrants
as criminals,
while he refuses to show us
his tax returns.
You could almost say the whole
thing is --
-A scam.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]